Algie gun wrist my name is fear to pass
welcome back to the moon we're nearing
the end of this we're finding out what's
really happening and we're at the
carnival
we just started here we jumped from the
last episode some kind of carnival
I like the music ah my decide shall we
look around how about I look around and
you just stand there I won with
continuous bacon in the form of question
for the pigs out yeah we could do that
quit blabbering and go already
ah you're ruinin whoa holy [ __ ] we're
fast
yay all right let's talk to them fruits
fresh fruits apples orange tomatoes we
got it all wait a minute
tomatoes are fruits and yeah they are
they are the ovaries of the plants and
contain Saints that's what it fruited
but come on tomato who gives a [ __ ] come
on we never ever referred to them as
bread we who I happen to enjoy cooking
in groups okay some of us take it very
safe thank you for that thank you for
that game but I don't want it stupid
toys we want to rape Gaytan
that's only train rat do you want to
exchange your prize for a teddy bear
instead no I just want to Train now now
John don't make a scene joy wanted
Ferris cry didn't he but I want Cho
he just went first hey it's okay I like
to play with it just see how nice your
brother is Charlie okay your jump links
don't block this down now come let's go
up see what's over there I'm not a
dumpling you know what I'm going to call
you dumplings from God you're bluffing
I can't get away from the music uh isn't
it a little weird how she ran over her
own son like how oh I don't see how you
can manage to do that in that scenario
oh yes it's not like she was stressed or
anything it was just a normal back out
the car okay oh yes fortunes of Wonders
are ahead of you this one might just
become a liar and this one the doctor oh
ma come on
I'm getting will for your tricks silly
mom hey where's my ten hey totally like
that sorry about your kids you don't
even get them trick okay this is a nice
memory
why are you everywhere it's creepy three
bars of memory well how in heaven I
don't have that maybe here up this
hammer hammer time
no give me bars fine I go something what
do you want welcome man behold the
world's smallest Ferris with haha
can we ride it absolutely not does it
even work absolutely not looks like
someone just glued some chairs to a
water wheel don't know don't care
yes it gave us a ball so I don't care
why don't the tomato dude give us balls
seriously
what about these hey is that a
whack-a-mole what got Wow whack-a-mole
you take a smaller check them all of
them Michael I love those I'm really
good at that
isn't that animal it is their fake Mouse
but hand
it's how people blew up steam before FPS
were invented it's also true before them
Call of Duty how primitive yeah it's
pretty ghetto where do you read about it
my grandpa was a fun what I know about
it and how them want to play just hit
everything on the head and you win yes
ah yes
oh I got to play yes oh hey watch this
[ __ ] up ah [ __ ] dig let's [ __ ] up die
die all your pace of shed I walk your
[ __ ] this game is amazing
die die [ __ ] Call of Duty and got
[ __ ] on this pitting bunch of turds
coming out of the hole
[ __ ] off turds dig let's or whatever the
hell you are
no not right I'm getting all of them now
I miss one son of a barrel I missed thus
come on dude 30 seconds left
yes yes yeah time top what do I win
let's see now
out of 44 targets you struck oh oh well
I got everyone except two I didn't know
they count my strug's 92 pretty far
right that's not really a 95% hit rates
more like a 50 brilliant hit rate at
your new record nail it
yes now we can go here okay um what is
this what is this Oh a ball thank you
one more ball it's gotta be here mm-hmm
I can never understand you Joey how can
you stand the tape of them they're just
so sour and icky it's the pickled olives
sour and awesome
you mean let's try it I don't think you
use the word awesome about 50 years ago
but hey that is just my vocabulary now I
don't even taste regular you should try
at least one Johnny who knows maybe
you'll like it
yeah and now he loves picking olives
that's kind of sad yeah I'm done though
can I go play okay but only at the
playground and not an inch to [ __ ] just
leave that bag and I'll keep trying no
it's mine I want it all right let's just
pick it all of us again to go back in
time
no I can't well [ __ ] okay
well it's like Mordor down there okay
what else we got to find the thing where
is it
here all right no problemo no what what
no no where's the what do you want no
way I'm talking to her good or bad I'm
screwing either way all right
I'm screwed either way I'm screwing
either way but with which items which
item did we go back in time with Susie
lo which item I wouldn't go here oh yeah
yeah Johnny wine over here I'm stupid go
all right we should get some conclusion
here on what's going on maybe here is
when we find out why they want to go to
the moon why is it lagging like a crazy
person all right
sorry the like is gone all right let's
follow these little pickled olives huh
way to follow your mom's order huh well
we're following him what and what he's
gonna go to a lighthouse this is where
the light is
I recognize this area yes I do what is
it Johnny Johnny are you scared that is
a rock you're right are you lost
he can't be long Johnny what's the
matter seriously though what's the
matter but whoa nice jump run what is
going on Wow
beautiful I love this tune it's so cute
add that gap deborah cow Wow his murder
well okay so we wandered off to trail
and find a cool place but that's facing
you could also been eaten by a pack of
tiger not really but Tigers don't travel
in packs you idiot I didn't even know
that it was just an expression you know
when I was a kid my grandpa took me to
stargazing every year yeah
there was a hell outside a city that
wouldn't stay I'm the same one in every
year we'd watch the stars till daybreak
well I did mostly he just carried the
telescope for me okay
of course the thing was though ma didn't
really want me to stay up late grandpa
always told her that we were just
camping
I had the telescope inside the car oh
that is juicy that's all good but when
we got back in the morning I had to
pretend like I'd actually slept
so in conclusion that's the story of how
I started my cavities oh man you're
terrible I know it's a shame though come
on let's see what's up with Johnny's
then cool story bro all these nice
memories lost and never found and who
knows how many more like it it's true
well as you say just take it moment by
moment right mm oh [ __ ]
I totally pax Tiggers dwell here what Oh
Tigers stupid sorry it's gonna be Joey
for sure no aah
Trevor no they met this early hello
wait don't go
I'm Johnny what's your name
you you're at my spot your spot oh I'm
sorry I didn't mean to hug this place
all by myself
you can sit together together I want to
join me are you here to watch the stars
are you
okay so yeah
yeah
what is happening beautiful arson that
the Ducks
you
just like Adam
did you know there were so many lights
in this guy yes oh I did too of course
he did of course in it you said this was
your spot right only during the carnival
not a fan of the crowds
me neither ya know you still haven't
told me your name yet
I'm not telling you everyone makes fun
of it and school
why I said it makes them want to go to
the washroom it's true oh okay then
well I can't be worse than Jong I mean
everyone in the world it's nearly
everyone's name John even in India
probably yes what's wrong with that
hmm what's wrong with having a name that
everyone else has strip
well it's boring I guess I mean if
everyone has it then what's the point
I'm kind of like John actually I went in
mine
just for once to have the same name as
everyone she just wants to be oh I get
it now
I get it now totally get it now
it's like those lights in the sky okay I
don't get it
what they all look the same premiere but
that doesn't make them any less pretty
I suppose what do you think those stars
are up there anyways my dad say they're
giant burning spheres of gas oh I bet it
he's just making out why would he lie to
me because you know that's what
grown-ups do they make things up
Santa is our buddy kangaroos what stuff
like that of course right I never
actually seen a kangaroo are they
telling me have you ever made an Easter
Bunny out of stars like a constellation
yes of other things never try to wrap it
though
so that's why she makes them do you want
to make one yeah we'll make the bestest
constellation ever let's see what makes
one first and that's why he doesn't
remember
and that's why she's sad I totally get
everything now okay we'll start in there
three two one and stop I see it way in
the sky um but we're in this guy think
big
bigger than the all the others
I don't know I don't know
wait a minute wait a minute ice and tell
me what you see
ah right two ears and a head what else
and then there is two feet
yes what off and and the moon the moon
is big round Bell so what do you think
they really are the stars I mean I I
never told anyone but tell us tell us
I always thought they were lighthouses
billions of lighthouses stuck at the far
end of the sky Wow
I must be sold it must be so lonely up
there but it isn't tell us River they
can see all the other lighthouse it out
there and they want to talk to them but
they can't because they're all too far
apart to hear what all the others are
saying all they can do is is shine their
lights from the fire so that's what they
did
they shine their lives at the other
lighthouses and Annie why you
because one day I'm going to befriend
one event Sakia so that's what was all
about the lion houses that bag was in it
Oh a surprise I want from the mahkum um
did you get to play that game
I tried but I'm too clumsy what did you
get from it I got a thing I don't really
know what it is it's the Platypus and he
would give it to her and oh my god
that's some kind of weird duck beaver
thing it's beaver
may I see it hmm suck out its giving it
to her and if she kept it for all this
time it looks so strange
I wish I could win mine my son Johnny
hey that's mom calling here you know
what keep it it's yours mine yeah I can
always get another I don't like to brag
but I'm totally the best of that game
will you be here next year
yep will you yes same place same time
yes
what what if you forget or get lost then
we can always regroup on them this is
just getting more and more Sun right on
the rabbit stock jolly coming
I forgot my hacky sack in the bank you
said you're clumsy right maybe it'll
help
if they ever get lost
wait does that mean don't tell me you
didn't see that coming
and here I thought this is gonna be an
inspirational childhood dream story I
should have known that some girl would
come along and turn into cheesefest
I suppose now we know what we must know
what we must do to send him to the moon
wait you aren't actually going to do it
are you it's our job Neil it's what
we're contacted there damn it Eva wait
Eva ah
all right buzz I can edit here
lack of effort if you enjoyed subscribe
comment a and I'll see you next episode
or for a bar make a breath probably next
last episode next one body [ __ ] bunny
they did it they did it easy today today
need a date 9900 this come on font
helmet Lady gaga